MARTIN KRCEK: I'm Martin Krcek.
And I'm Marketing Director
of Madfinger Games.
Today I will teach
you how I created
a huge community of
68 million players.
One is you can go and buy
new users, new players,
but it's quite very expensive.
The second one is to
create your own community.
It takes some time,
but you will have
your fans who will
love your game.
At the beginning, we
started with zero actually.
But we created the first game.
We created activities on
Facebook and other social
media, like Twitter,
like Google+.
Also, we started a
web page to bring
and to show what
is this game about.
And we started slowly increasing
the number of players,
then we sent them newsletters.
We sent them push
notifications and, again,
created interesting
topics, events for them
to bring them back to the
game and to share these games
or events with their friends.
So the community was
increasing during that time.
We used two types of content.
One is saying what's
new in the game.
And the second one we are acting
on real-life activities which
is going on around us.
For example, we did
European elections
for zombies, which are
going to the Parliament.
And it was focused on the
European Parliament campaign.
During the world
championship in football,
we created really
funny videos, which
showed that our
characters are also
playing football,
[? enjoying ?] this game.
Every week, all players
can go back to our game
and play our tournaments.
And for this, we use
[INAUDIBLE] channels,
like push notifications.
To all of our users,
we send them messages.
We use Facebook to post and
promote these events and also
other activities.
During the week,
all of the community
is talking that
this weekend there
will be really
amazing tournaments.
And they can win some
in-game currency,
gold, or iPad, for
example, this week.
So they are looking
forward to the weekend.
And during the weekend, they
are going to the tournaments
and they play.
A few weeks ago,
in Europe, there
were huge European elections
to the European Parliament.
So we decided to bring something
interesting also for our users,
for our players.
So we created that
our zombies are
going to the European
Parliament, too.
So we created a campaign.
And our users could
go to our website
and vote which zombie will be
the best one in the European
Parliament.
And we also created the trailer
commercial for this election.
So everyone went to the website.
They voted for his favorite
zombie and watched the movie
and shared it with
their friends.
So during the
elections, I can say,
it was a nice
topic for everyone,
because everyone was talking
about the European elections.
And we bring something
interesting to them,
which is very closely
connected with our game.
So our community loves it.
And we were really fascinated
from their feedback
on our Facebook page
or from our support.
The football World Cup was a
very interesting topic for us,
because it took one month.
And we had lots of
time to think about it
and to bring something
funny for our players.
So every day, we
posted some activities
from the football
match that some zombies
are fans of this football.
One zombie posted his
selfie from the stadium.
All the stuff is interesting
for us, not only because
of the fans, but because
we are increasing
in number of users,
in number of players.
Right now we have more
than 68 million players
around the world and something
like 1.1 million fans
on Facebook.
And also this huge
number of players
can earn us interesting
money, so we
can continue to develop this
game and bring to our players
interesting stuff.